le syndrome était arrivé là évidemment
pourriez alors bâtiment burrier que ça
même vous faire et cette unité d'une
faune et le routard croissance ort n'est
pas seulement devant je pense plutôt les
deux têtes
bonjour bonjour mademoiselle mentait je
suis la salle entré chez les entrées
bonjour monsieur attendu avec impatience
installez-vous et oui mon père je vais
vous poser quelques questions faut avoir
un petit peu pourquoi ce retard de
croissance chez ce bébé vous avez quel
âge elle a 30 ans dont trente ans c'est
bien ça lui trente ans c'est ce que j'ai
dit oui vous avez des enfants
oui on est un petit garçon s'appelle
romain et la patron mais là il n'est pas
là il à l'école d'accord
un petit garçon de quatre ans donc oui
c'est bien ça montre à l'animal
oui elle travaillait des infirmiers mais
l arrêté pour s'occuper du petit on va
pas laisser n'importe qui s'occuper de
nos enfants d'une jours surtout qu'on a
un problème là
il devait un retard de croissance est ce
que il ya des problèmes de santé dans
votre famille à sa famille mon dieu
heureusement que j'étais là je lis
interdit de fréquenter sa famille et
heureusement justement que j'étais là
parce que maintenant elle se sent mieux
donc sa part madame parce que sa famille
est complètement dingue
et vous madame vous avez des problèmes
de santé elle est complètement folle
c'est pour ça que je l'aï été a dit de
sortir
je sais ce qu'il est capable de faire on
va faire le point par rapport à votre
alimentation comment ça se passe
alimentation madame est complètement
alors ixic anorexique
vous êtes occupé en ce moment préoccupé
beau faire battre à se plaindre je vois
pas d'autres occupations
bon apparemment c'est un petit peu tendu
j'aurais dû lorsqu'on est un peu tendue
nous non non en fait je voulais vous
proposer quelques exercices de
relaxation sas à ya du bien pour le bébé
également donc au québec je vous le seul
vous désirez peut-être à café madame
voulons qu'ils merci ok mais je voudrais
pas ça de suite jours et toi je te
propose rien parce que tu portes ou
dégueuler sam hamad
il me semble que vous êtes victime de
violences conjugales quoi mais il m'a
jamais frappé
e